yes we did cuz we back at it again it's
the fighter in the kid this is really
the fighter in the kid come on baby guys
we're just talking about trucks and the
subculture that is trucks I want to get
you over onto the truck side dude dude I
got to get on the truck side dude I
spent all morning at King shocks in
Orange Grove California it's crazy
they're here so it's only about an hour
only about an hour drive yeah it it's
the it's like the it's the the bees
knees when it comes to off-road
suspension
they're the guys man that's like me
talking about wide receivers in the NFL
like me faking that I'm into trucks
would be like can you imagine if I was
like all right this is my angle I want
to make a lot of money guys I'm in the
trucks now oh boy yeah that'd be tough
it would be like that thing be a good
debut video of me just taking my TX and
driving over your your Tesla and you
being like yeah and I'm not gay anymore
well Joe I don't like men's anymore
Rogan had the best uh description of of
what it's like when you're faking
something he said he was about talking
about this one guy and he goes he says
he's straight but whenever he talks
about women it sounds like a guy who is
pretending to speak French but he
doesn't know French it was such a
great giberish it's like oh hold on
you're dude I took her and I'm [__]
just shredded that [__] I was [__]
hitting it all night it's like you're 50
why are you
I don't quite believe you I think you
bang guys that is weird yeah yeah I'll
tell you who it is when I you could be a
truck you might know who it is I bet I
do yeah I bet I do yeah we'll talk are
you are you oh you'll be on stage the
big UFC 296 I'll be on stage uh it's the
best card it's the very go see Brian but
also watch the UFC the fight campanion
I'll be watching you be conflicted but
watch it on your phon while Brian's on
stage I'm deing with Cheeto ver and
Rampage wow wow 7 P.M live thick boy you
is officially fighting sea for the title
right that's huge yeah uh what but the
card is the UFC is going out with a
banger the main card dude take my
freaking money that I'd probably put him
to my truck but take my freaking money
well let's go through it um was sente
luk Ian Machado Gary you got to go with
Ian Machado right just because he's on
the upswing and there's a lot of
pressure on him yeah I was saying this
on the shop show and I'll even elaborate
on it the to me the the best thing about
the UFC is the come up like when Conor
was coming up when kabib was coming up
khabib's made his debut when on my fight
card not a big deal I was on the main
card he undercard not a big deal dude
it's it is what it is I don't have
control of it y um but with Ian Machado
Gary like this come up is great but it's
come to screeching halt because of his
PR team there's all this bad press and
all that stuff but he he's the guy but
here's the thing all the noise him being
a cuck his girl this bad press all that
goes away if he wins if it just as Al
Davis says the Raiders just win baby if
he head kicks vente luk there's not much
you can it's just people okay that guy's
really good and you forget about but
right now he's like in this limbo where
you think people are rooting against him
when I say people rooting against him I
mean I've never seen anything like it
why because he's it's almost like is it
because of the way he treated Neil Magny
or is it just because it's a number of
things
it's just this perfect storm of people
think he's fake and like he says one
thing then they actually have old video
of him saying another so it's not
authentic him being a cuck and then him
copying Conor McGregor it's like this
whole [__] storm of negativity going on
around this insanely talented kid insan
he's not listening to any of this and
that's and only hanging with his dime
piece of a wife yeah and getting sucked
off but here's the thing um I'd love to
see that no I'm not cck that's your
thing no I'd watch it here's the thing
though I this is what's interesting if
he loses on
Saturday it's
over cuz cuz those trolls all that toxic
[__] 10 times more
just you're when I say feeding the
trolls yeah he's dumping loads in their
mouth just here you go here you go here
raw chickens to crocodiles yeah it's
just it just gets and it's just going to
bury them and the UF see they're they're
Market Savvy they they're social media
Savvy they're going to go he's too hated
we can't we can't we can't really you
think so oh man they they do this all
the time same same as like Leon Edwards
who's the main event he's so talented
though this kid has a lot of fight left
in him but we've never of course he does
yeah but you you can diminish this
insane star this insane Talent with If
he if he is paying attention to this
he's [__] it I am officially rooting
hard for Ian Mach I got so much [__] for
being like I'm I'm rooting for hard for
him but the when I say the entire fan
base the entire MMA space is rooting
against this guy but this all goes away
they're fickle they're prisoners of the
moment he head kicks vente luk and looks
spectacular people go he's got he's a c
but that dude is [__] dope you know
but but is it that but like think think
how much [__] Jon Jones has had in his
career how much toxic awful stuff when
he fights do you think of any of that no
why because he wins now if he loses I'm
still so confused by the amount of hate
like this kid is just literally just
showed up and won a lot he's cocky he's
theatrical he's he's married with they
don't think it's authentic and then also
it's a it's a version we've seen so he
Connor's his hero so he mimics Conor but
Connor he's just he can do it in Spades
that's his thing like he was born with
that gift Ian's not so so people find it
inauthentic and if you're not authentic
people didn't smell that out his issue
is I I just want to sit him down like
budy you don't have to do it's too late
but you don't have to do this you're so
talented F talk your [__] that's fine
but don't don't mimic Conor you do your
create your own lane yeah and then the
worst thing it is he's wearing Brazilian
colors I think M oh boy oh boy who the
[__] he's Irish right is he Irish or is
he English as Irish as you get as Irish
as it gets Irish as it gets you don't do
that you don't do that because don't
wear the bra you're not Brazilian don't
wear the Brazilian colors are you out of
your mind you're wearing Brazil colors
you're fighting a Brazilian who the f
you're from Dublin you're from Ireland
[__] told you think about think about
his PR team they went how else can we
[__] this kid over oh wow his watch from
Brazil so let's have him be a Trader and
go completely opposite of Dublin which
is a massive fan base and they support
everyone they still support Conor after
all his [__] let's let's let's go
away from them and go to Brazil Brazil
is like what espe especially when
there's all this a pride Irish Pride now
through through all the immigration I
wish you would stop doing that voice CU
that's I'm from Ireland my family is
from Dublin good my family is from
Dublin yeah and I'm rooting for Ian
Machado Gary even the Machado things
it's like what are you doing dude you're
Ian Gary you're not you're not take his
wife's middle name yes and so did you I
did not yeah you did no I didn't I
thought you did you told me that and I
just didn't want to you out of here M
I'm a [__] I'm so masculine it's
crazy dude you did that no I didn't
don't spread that ter don't spread that
terrible R I thought you did I'm being
serious what a shitty I thought you did
what a shitty rumor I thought you going
change your stage day is my is my name
is my name Brian R Callen yeah I thought
that's what I just thought it was is it
Brian did I did I also keep my my
ex-wife's name Brian Humphrey R call is
that what I'm doing I guess I don't I
thought I thought it was your thing man
oh my God what type of dudes do that is
so funny no I thought you had to do that
when you buy
Teslas don't you have to take your
wife's name when you buy a Tesla and you
have to get a tattoo of cuck on on the
base of your on your lower spine it's
branded ow [__] [__] [__] [__] yeah o
scratched out with a u yeah with him
it's just taking your wife's name cuck
move not wearing the flying the Dublin
flag cuck move it's just he if what he's
going to do if the if they if the UFC
gets to a point where you can study UFC
fighters there's going to be a marketing
101 it's going be a face of Ian Machado
Gary but if he wins we're all talking
about him he's the heel and maybe as
long as he wins you can do any of this
[__] right to win has to win got to win
a lot of pressure the all the pressure
and then here's the question is he not
listening to it and is he good enough to
pull this off might be if he's smart
noten you want my answer yes absolutely
yeah and that's why's that talented
freak just horrible marketing yeah
terrible
wife well probably wife mistaken too not
not the best at publicity kind of like a
Brian K in terms of branding and oh
you're Nike compared to them they're the
worst I've ever seen today you guys
they've ruined this young Lion's career
you're going to love this so I'm sitting
in I'm sitting there at my the kitchen
table my kid is walking around my wife
is just kind of doing her thing The
Nanny we have a nanny now because my
wife had to run some errands and I had
to go to work okay yeah so uh uh so I'm
sitting there and I'm trying to think of
like ideas of how to stay relevant in
this Tik Tok world at 56 it's tough and
I go like this I go I'm just sitting
there I've come up with a thousand ideas
they haven't really you
know yeah and so uh I
go I go ah go I'm looking at the my view
and I
go I go do you think I should have a
live a live news show every day for like
20 minutes and I just heard her she goes
like this she goes definitely
not absolutely not I'm like what no she
goes no plan for that not going to work
that's not and I got mad for a second I
was like but she's right then she goes
hey do you want um do you want to get do
you want to pick up some packs and maybe
some paper towels to and I go no I don't
want to do any of that I don't want to
do that I want to figure out how to stay
relevant I got I snap back at her I got
all pissy yeah and I was like sorry
you're you're going through it man you
figure it out the guy would know help me
figure it out man that's the best right
that's nothing better that's hey I I got
to make some money I also I got this hey
man I'm having a tough time paying the
rent you figure out it's like do in two
days you'll figure it out yeah you get
it oh you get it I'll be homeless you go
yeah e my buddy Jimmy Burke used to do
that if no matter what the problem i' be
like [__] I he go ah you get
it that is the it's so funny it's so
frustrating I was so mad cuz my girl was
my girl had broken up with me and she
was dating this dude and it was in my
neighborhood and and I and I just
couldn't [__] I was just like [__]
you know I got mad about some other
thing I couldn't figure out how to the
fridge got stuck you know with the
drawer and I go it's [__] fridge man
he could tell I was mad about that thing
and he goes ah you get it it makes you
laugh but it's so
frustrating that's why I'd send a text
to Ian Gary ah you get it you get it no
help no help at all that kid is I don't
think there's been more pressure on a
fighter since maybe Conor kabib only if
he's listening to all of this stuff
right you don't know he's young he's 27
and he's he's pretty active on social
media he's talked back to the haters on
social media that makes me a little
worried yeah he turned his comments off
I think that's his wife let me see this
it's not a good idea that means they got
you it's not always be haters it's my
time to respond yeah so he posted this
video after all the
stuff
they hate the way you walk they hate the
way you talk they hate that on December
16th they'll all be watching you win
again stupid has to win this episode of
the fighter and the kid usfc 296
breakdown is brought to you by house of
macademia that's right 100% pure
macademia nuts not just for the rich
anymore House of mamus farmed from over
90 freaking Farms so it's at a great
price for you guys no added sugars oil
stabilizers all right it's fantastic
they got it all for you they also got
Macadamia milk that's right that black
coffee is's not cutting it get you a
gallon a free gallon of macademia milk
when you visit House of macademia is.com
sltf AK just add the milk to your cart
and with any products use the code TFK
and by products I mean their chocolate
covered macadamia nuts my absolute
freaking favorite they get the regular
Sala macadamias they get the 4 5%
macadamia nut bars they have everything
you need to get your thick ass in shape
and do it it delicious style that's
house academia.com TFK just add the milk
to your cart with any products and use
the code TFK and you get a g Gallen of
macadamia milk for
free I'm excited he's got me excited as
[__] for that fight I think that's the
best fight on the card I couldn't I
can't wait and can can I get some color
on vente L vente L I like saying Chante
can I get some color on him he's he's
been doing it for a hot damn second yeah
and he gets hit he likes a slug he he's
he's a beast yep I mean look at that he
won one two three four four in a row he
lost to Wonder Boy Beat Nico price Randy
Brown coming off of a very bad brain
bleed too he's he's coming off well he's
two and he's lost two of his last three
beat uh dos angos but he he's a he's
good at everything hits like a m oh no
joke I think he's ranked ahead of uh I
think he's seven b that's how good balah
Mohammad is by the way yeah bah is very
good yeah but still bah couldn't put him
away a decision you know like this is a
tough fight for V sente luk yeah I it's
the most interesting fight on the card I
think by far that's that's that's going
to be exciting um there's just so much
pressure on that kid the Chante L mostly
uh what is his biggest strength he's
good at everything hits like a MC truck
great Muay Thai great kickboxing black
belt on the ground yeah you know just
and and we haven't seen even Machado
Garry's ground game he supposed to be
pretty good but we don't we haven't seen
it cuz he he he out strikes everybody
but before when he was in cage Warriors
he used a lot of wrestling a lot of
grappling then he gets the UFC he's a
straight Striker you know so um he is he
is a
killer yeah but
um he we haven't seen him against the
top guys yet not yet Rodriguez Daniel
Rodriguez was a good matchup for him
he's a complet Striker boxer good boxer
he annihilated him that Neil mag's
always perennial top 10 he he should
been charged with a felony for what he
did to Neil Magny it wasn't a fight no
joke he [__] he tenderized his leg I
know NE you know that's insane so he so
he's Leaps and Bounds above everybody
but we haven't seen him against the top
six guys but he beats vente luk he gets
on the mic rips a hot promo calling out
Sean Strickland for making fun of him
probably fight at middleweight fight
Leon Edwards like that he's he's won 18
months I bet he's fighting for World
title but again only if he wins Saturday
night yeah he don't win Saturday night I
don't know I think it's get very tough
for him if he doesn't
win very tough for him the UFC is going
to make it tough on him the fan base
make it tough on him it's a lot for a
27y old kid man [__] yeah and that's why
I'm rooting for him and all the the fan
base just prisoners of the moment what
do you care why the [__] do you care
saying is a cuck if the guy he's not a
[__] no I'm just saying but okay what if
he is who gives a flying [__] I don't
care I don't why people care he's a
warrior too he's like you well that's
Bonafide of these guys I'm saying I'm
saying this I I I I wish people like
anytime you've tried to be really good
at anything right like it it's really
hard and and it never ends being hard
it's always really hard to keep it do
you know how hard it is to get to where
he's gotten you know how [__] hard
that is to to train like that all the
time time to be that good all the time
it's a [__] yeah he's talented
but that comes with a lot of work a lot
of work so so let's go back to the card
for a sec the the only cavey out there
with Ian G I stick up for him that as
far as personal life I don't know why
you guys care it's just the Real
Housewives of the UFC sure it's just
drama you know something else to talk
about but with IMA the one thing where
I'm like that there could be a problem
there he's been kicked out of multiple
gems for what we're not sure that's very
interesting some of it is he always has
a camera filming he he's always like
he's he's very outgoing you know talk
[__] and then he always has a camera and
some guys are like dude we're not
filming this he's like no I need the
content so there's some of that maybe
clashes with
coaches when I hear that stuff I'm like
that's a problem but I do know guys I
won't mention names who are way more
famous than in Gary exact same problem
so they just started their own gyms CU
they don't they don't play well with
others it's literally they're narcissist
and most Fighters are and it has to be
their way or the highway anybody else
can kick rocks that's what makes them
great y they're tough to deal with Jon
Jones got kicked out of
Jackson there's a ton of guys that have
been kicked out they start their own
teams and it's only about them Ian might
be one of those guys Jon Jones got
kicked out of uh Jackson did they what
was do you have any color on that was
that like Old Bubba but but were they
like we don't want you name of Reason
really you serious just bad publicity I
mean dude firing guns at homeless uh
wrecking a car well drunk uh but he
there he was he was there through all
that no no no they kicked him out the
main one was the the kids you know at
the hotel the wife was like scared that
that's oh I forgot he beat up his wife
yeah that's right and the kids went and
told security Brian's like I don't get
it he had a he headbut a police car yeah
that would be like sorry they don't care
he headbut the police car he headbut his
wife that's the issue it's not a good
headbut the police car we don't give a
[__] yeah there too many issues they fin
like oh God damn we got to get out of
here I mean but then when guys go on
their own some some
flourish but that that's that's a little
bit of a red flag when you're kicked out
of multiple gyms again it's a red flag
or it just means all right don't play
well with others it's his show yeah so
you get to a certain level just start
your own [__] yep but that's something
to be cautious of whenever guys's
getting kicked on mul gens you're like
yes this guy's a problem but he just
might be he might be a lot where he
[__] up chemistry of a team he's
definitely a lot he's definitely a lot
maybe I don't he's playing a character
but you know what I'm saying like maybe
like Kobe cson is a great teammate
people love that guy Kobe's a lot got
Ked he's a character top team yeah but
he went up to another team they love him
yeah like he's a character he's playing
a character Ian might be playing a
character or he's like this 247 they're
like dude you're [__] up the
chemistry you got to get out of here
yeah but I just I don't see how you
don't we're talking we're talking about
him and I can't wait everyone's talking
about him but I just don't see how you
can't root for that like if you're not
rooting for this guy and what you know
what he's up against if he loses it's
going to get pretty dark for him I don't
who cares what he does in his personal
life why you don't root for that I don't
understand I don't neither that's just
Society like they want oh my God kid so
talented you might like uh uh um Neil
Magny and I I was very confused at how
insulting he was to Neil Magny like
after he won it was weird again because
he's playing a he's playing a character
yes and no but he's playing a character
that's a page out of Conor McGregor's
book but when it's not your thing it
comes off as inauthentic and mean yeah
so when you talk about and this is again
this just him being young and dumb which
I can forgive he's 27 when you talk
about Neil magd beating his children
Neil did an interview goes you don't
understand the problems that caused that
that wasn't an issue before the fight
after the fight I almost lost my [__]
children yeah he goes child custody came
and almost took my [__] kids because
you spread this rumor and there's no
there's no there's no truth to it
whatsoever I was making a statement you
can get sued for that [__] man that's
[__] suing you can lose your kids so
it's like he was like he doesn't
understand his his actions [__] my
life up like I almost lost the thing I
care about most Ian G's 27 he's trying
to be like Connor made a huge mistake
yeah I can forgive that but he he has to
find his path right now he's mimicking
Conor's but you don't want to do that
you there's a there's only one Conor
also con's also funny Conor was also
like had a lot of funny because it's his
but because he's he's speaking his truth
like he would do this whether was a
fighter or if he a doesn't matter but I
I think with Conor also do you want
Conor's career do you want his bank
account yes do you want his career that
guy's hated man he was beloved he was
the jewel of Dublin now a lot of people
don't don't don't claim him they don't
want to be associated with all that
negativity so it's like Ian he went down
that road but there's a certain level
you got to stop Atman yeah he's just a
young kid it's like you don't want to
end up like Conor the bank account I get
all that I want that too but as far as
the Press you don't want those problems
dude it's not good the lawsuits the
constant women claiming they got
pregnant you don't want that [__]
slapping people in bars getting fights
in bars you don't want that [__] dude
that's Conor don't be like that be
better yeah like if you're if you're if
you love Connor be better don't don't
have to do all this [__] do your talking
with your [__] fist and your feet do
that dude be different than Conor more
people would love him love him he's a
good guy if he wins if he wins this
fight though I'm I'm all in he has such
an opportunity to win this fight and get
on the mic and drop the [__] hotest
promo and get that next you think he he
should call out uh oh he should get on
there and call Shan Strickland a cuck a
racist a former Nazi go so hard in the
pain at Sean Strickland the UFC goes we
got to make it
happen that's what he should do that's
the big money fight that's the
move but again his wife she's
like call out Francis call out Francis
call out Francis okay wifey yeah is that
what she said [__] idiot dude did she
say that yeah call Francis I don't know
some [__] you would do what call
Canelo just some bull do makes no
sense you know what I'm saying like
don't do that about her don't make her
face like that that's not well it's
[__] stupid what I've never seen this
face on her I've never seen that so
please don't do that all right um well
just think of the worst call out ever
yeah and that's what he's going to come
up with she's in the back like I think
you should call it a trans fighter he's
got he's got like a he's got a little
earpiece he's like hold on trans are
there yeah okay um you know Jake Paul
well just a quick correction just just
or he's going to really [__] himself
like I'm calling that transgender
fighter and just girl who's not trans
and just ruin his career some girls be
like what the [__] I'm not a oh my God
you know like that's some horrible PR
move that she's going to come up with
yep yep called this fire and some poor
girl's like I'm not trans you piece of
[__] who uh what do you think of the
Tony Ferguson real quick just just so
the audience knows so Ian Gary is
actually 26 267 yeah that makes him even
younger which is a big you know one year
is a big deal 26 I was I'm I'm 40 I'm a
26 dude I was an idiot at 26 I'm still
an idiot but I'm less of an idiot yeah
I'm less of an idiot
barely yeah but 26 dude and you have all
this Fame and talent through he's
[__] pissing Talent dude he He Turned
26 in November so he just turned
26 baptism by fire you're going to learn
quick and and and the and the good ones
can handle this the good ones can handle
and show the [__] up mhm
hand they like the pressure it's like
Bryce Harper at baseball they asked the
coach cuz he hit that game win home run
uh you know in the the playoffs and they
went you how's this guy do it like he's
been hurt half the season and then the
the game's on the line he's like for
whatever reason when the odds are
stacked against him Bryce Harper is the
exact guy you want up he thrives if it's
just a regular day game he does all
right if the pressure's all on him he'll
hit home run is it crazy they're like
when it's bases feel that way
down three runs this kid this [__]
guy is the exact person you cuz he
thrives in that moment yeah I feel that
way about Shan not yet but he'll get
yeah he definitely show some people just
show up their best days when it's all
all counts yeah agree you can say that
about Jon Jones probably too you know
any some of these guys are just train
who are I would say about joh yeah he's
just so talented yeah he's just better
than um I didn't know Josh Hammet and
Bryce Mitchell look like they're in
different weight classes it's it was a
late second replacement fight Bry
Mitchell stepping in for that it's a
tough fight for Bryce and I love had
time he had fight he took a lot of
damage tough fight dude tough F yeah
Josh EMT strong it's like a MC truck
tough to take down short
base I don't like the fight for Bryce
yeah that's a tough one Josh Tony
Ferguson uh Patty Pimm's an interesting
one it's not that interesting to me I I
would rather I would rather Tony
Ferguson I was thinking about this and I
was thinking that what were you thinking
never he never was the same after the
Justin gy fight and they should have
stopped that fight oh at least two
rounds in that's yeah I think he was
even before that but he's been fighting
for he has all the miles on them here's
here's my thing you ready for this ready
for this hot take if Tony can pull that
the terrible picture of but if Tony can
if Tony can pull this off you know he
fights
next okay uh um it could are you gonna
say Nate Diaz nope that's stupid right
hold on hold on hold on hold on he's not
even in the UFC right hold on are you ma
Gary's wife Tony Ferguson if he beats
get on the mic call out Nate beats Patty
pimp what if he beats Patty pimp yes his
next fight if he wins his next fight
who's he fight Francis
andano Francis andano dude I'd watch
that right hell yeah I'd watch that uh
no he fights uh uh Conor McGregor no yep
what
yep no yep that would be very strange to
me why would it be strange they've spoke
they were supposed to fight before Conor
needs a win Conor's probably not going
to beat Michael Chandler Tony's coming
off a win they they're both big Legend
names Conor needs a win is Conor gonna
fight Michael Chandler yes youc 300
maybe a little after that but he that
fight's going to happen you don't think
he's going to be going be a very tough
fight for him yeah I don't I'm rooting
for you know Conor's onon my face so I
love Chandler too but Conor's won my
face so let's say he loses that fight
the UFC is like ah we got to get one
more who you going to throw him to what
what's a fight he can win at this level
he's not that active actually I'd like
to see him fight Patty piml that's I'd
like to see a Conor McGregor Patty piml
fight that's what I Conor's not taking
that fight why because he's not even
ranked in the top 30 and you think Patty
beats him Conor yeah I I gotta see what
version of Conor we get but I'd probably
take Conor that's fair yeah Patty
striking is very amateur so Patty Conor
lights him up Patty in UFC wouldn't do
that to Patty you're going to ruin this
star no no no but we can ruin Tony yeah
but but we also need to to get Conor a
win who who are you going to give him we
got to get this guy a [__] win what
are we going to do top five we can't
keep doing that no Tony's if he beats
Patty he's coming off a big win over
Patty MH everyone knows who he is he and
let's say he's back better than ever
cool here's Connor yeah it sells
everyone's going to buy all the cash
from like Tony F you know like a ninef
fight winning streak you know they're
stupid right I uh I don't want to see
Tony Ferguson fighting anymore but
you're a hater because if he beats Patty
if if he beat Patty but let's say he
does I'm saying if he beats
Patty I don't care what happens in the
cter fight he has paid more money than
God which he well earned yeah he he
should have all the money he can ride
off from the sunset yeah just take fight
one more after this that's all we need
out of you and you make all the money
can ride off from the I guess what I see
with is I see uh I
see um the movement of his body to be
not what it used to be and I'm not
talking about age it feels like it's I
think it's both it's a combo of both and
I hate damage and there's nothing I hate
seeing more than that I literally can't
stare at yeah that's tough it's like I I
hate seeing when I see an old fighter go
trying to make a comeback and they're
punching like this and I go I would I
would rather look at anything else cuz
that's that's cognitive [__] off like I
hate that Patty Pet's got the biggest
face he could sometimes he looks great
right now yeah he's he's 155 pound guy
but when he puts on when he eats his
head his head when I when he's on food
truck he was 230 he
what did you say to me 2:30 what no 230
and and every bit of 6 feet bring up the
picture of us we get me next door and
and I'm and remember I'm I'm about 240
something now remember in this picture
I'm 260 goe and bring that up 2:30 2:30
I I went insane look at him I went what
are you
doing I go what happens if they do a
short notice fight he's like I would
never do a short notice fight why do
they do you know dirty that was you
Brandon God you were [__] heavy
that's me and Patty right there had some
tits on you um but look at his face
there yeah no I mean it's insane he ate
like burgers he's got he did I had one
he had three and then went and watched
uh picture of him looks like I need a
picture with you little there's a
picture of me and him side by side Laugh
Factory there huh yeah Laugh Factory San
Diego cuz I had to do it in San Diego oh
I got you oh he oh um but I don't see
how about I just go to the food trck di
episode yeah it's crazy though right I
mean
damn damn I want to fight him now he
looks understand
it yeah could you understand
him uh yeah Brazil F of me I'm 260 there
really good right here especially if
find in Brazil he's every bit as thick
as he's every bit as thick as you are
yeah that's uh his head is bigger than
yours actually B you don't look bigger
though yeah I'm 260 there shorter hair
too but yeah yeah you skinny right now
what are you about 240 for real yeah 240
yeah you're skin 260 in that look at
look at Patty oh my Lord big hands he's
a big kid man I mean he's got a big big
frame great guy Superstar just has that
you know how the the too Brothers you're
like Jesus Christ just have that sauce
that's Patty yeah soon as you me like oh
love this Charisma love this game yeah
star PR he's such a good person oh this
guy's great yeah he seems Seems like a
sweetheart all right go back to the card
I love this Tony Patty yeah I'm of
course that's a fun fight yeah uh sha
cot Wonder Boy Tough fight for Wonder
Boy yeah I would say Tony has a better
chance of winning than Wonder Boy does
really really shot's the guy yeah damn
shot probably gets a title shot after
this he's a monster look at him that's
what the UFC's g a little bit of uh
little bit of a pickle there because if
I Machado Gary just storms over vente
luk then shavkat wins do you do shot Ian
it's not nice to Ian it's great fight
but you have two contenders that
division could use it that's it yeah I
know I want to see his face are oh his
face yeah he's such a bad don't know who
he is you have no clue you have to see
his face yeah that that's the guy but he
usually fights at uh 85 absolutely not
he doesn't no absolutely not yeah he
does he fought I think he fights it I
think he started at 85 BBA that's why I
want that make sure I was talking about
I think he positive yes I'm almost
positive he started he used to fight at
85 for sure and the fights I saw him at
started at welterweight he started
welterweight they a cat at 176 he's
never fought at middleweight ever in his
life really here's the thing you don't
know who he is and that's fine no you
don't and you thought he was a
middleweight you think he's Hamot and
that's fine he's tall he's a tall guy
he's not tall see how tall he is he's
not tall especially for the division
well 61 he's tall 6'1 no I know exactly
who he is I've seen him no cuz you
thought he was a middleweight right no I
thought he fought 85 F 85 before that
never he's never fought at 85 since 2014
he fought at welterweight so all right
that's a long time ago all right he
started fighting at 2014 just at
welterweight pro at least beat Alexa
look at that [__] oh you're probably
talking about his amateur career you
probably watch some of that I don't know
I saw I saw him fighting and I thought
it was 85 he fine you just learn who he
is so he's the guy with the fur hat
remember I swear to God I know who he is
I know exactly you don't I don't care a
monster and I think he got hurt for a
while true or false he's been inactive
yes no I know exactly who he is we don't
know why he didn't get hurt we don't
know why the reason I know he is is
because everybody was talking about him
everybody's like he's you know we've
been talking about him for years he's
the next guy yeah he's the guy if it's a
bank on anybody being world champion
it's yeah and and Wonder Boy 170 17
finishes wonder booy is 41 years old
yeah that's a tough one well Wonderboy
complained about paying the UFC went is
that what they did no problem is that
what is that what they do call him shot
oh my God you ready to eat Daddy really
that's what they do to you that's what
they do here we're going to give you a
young upand cominging killer who does
everything well and I the Ian Machado
shaat it doesn't why kill two young
lines like let them let one of them take
out Leon and then have another have a
fight and then they fight each other
okay so go keep let me go back to the
card now um but I I do think Tony has a
better shot of
winning and then you have your co-main
event nobody's talking about nobody
cares about uh Pantoja and Brandon Roy
Val yeah great fight going for Brandon
Roy Val Denver's finest and then you
don't have to click on it we're also not
going to cover sure as [__] not cover on
this show and then you have uh the main
event Leon Edwards Kobe Covington yeah
who you got lyanna
Colby depends what version of Colby we
get I'm G to tell you I'm I'm I'm going
with
Kobe but the only reason I'm going with
Kobe is because I think Kobe is going to
if he's smart about this is going to be
in his grill he's not going to be at a
distance where Leon Edwards can hit
that's the only way Kobe he's going be
in his there's no other way to fight
right that's all he does he's going to
well he'll he sometimes he tries to you
know stand and back he's in your grill
though he's applying pressure he never
fights on that outside and and that's a
problem for Leon Edwards that's it's
going to be tough really I think so bear
twice doing that kamaro did the exact
remember the first the first fight he
the first fight with kamaro kamaro was
absolutely dominating and dominating him
with his wrestling just may being a pain
in the ass to him then he got head
kicked and then what happened in the
second fight second fight started
learning cuz Leon got better right did
he get better or did Camaro's knees not
allow him to train Leon hasn't been able
to run for years Leon hasn't I mean I'm
sorry Camaro hasn't yeah but his knees
have always I think these things catch
up to you you know I think that Camaro I
think I think Camaro was the perfect
tuneup to fight Kobe he's done it twice
now all he's he's had two years to work
on just takedown defense Kobe hasn't
fought in a hot minute two years he's
had one's been active one hasn't he has
world class striking Kobe has to try to
get inside and not get [__] merked
tough fight for him tough to tough to
get right and also what version of Colby
are we get H fought in two years he only
has one way to win decision he's a buz
saww he's just going to
be though camar out buz Colby yeah and
Leon beat him twice that's true that's
[__] who am I rooting for Colby who
would I put money on Leon really yeah
and I love Kobe top five favorite you
think you think Leon sort of either
keeps get every time he get close yes I
think one's getting better and one's not
really yep H we know exactly what Kobe's
going to do Leon's getting better man
every time we see him like Jes his
takedown defense he took tomorrow down
yeah yeah well a real athlete who's
better athlete would you say between
Colby and Leon yeah I don't know tough
who's got more speed who's got more I
know what you're doing here I know what
you're doing I know what you're doing
what cuz Leon's black I know you I am I
didn't even
know lit one can Sprint way faster down
to his KN I'm sorry I I literally just
reminded that he is black I don't I I
literally was just I just know you're
doing iamp
I know you're trying to P me a pickle
her uh's more athletic so so so you
might be going you might be saying uh
knockout oh yeah really oh yeah not the
distance goes distance Kobe
wins but under five Leon all day how
how's I know what I I don't know how to
take that I don't know yeah I guess
you're trying to do there though if if
if if Kobe is if Kobe can get Grill Kobe
Take Kobe wins what' you say if KOB can
close distance really quickly and yeah
he's going to even if he gets hit he's
going to if he can close that distance
uh Leon has his hands full full and and
and so it really is a question of Ken
Leon for five rounds keep him at that
distance exact enough punishment that's
what he does and then stop the takedowns
he's the best in the world at it that's
why he's Champion yeah tough fight for
Kobe two years off his last win was over
Jorge mozol before that he lost twice to
kamaro okay and I'm a Kobe Di Rider I
love the kid yeah awful fight for him
also is he even deserving of this title
shot most would say no you're two and
two you haven't fought in two years your
last win was over hor mazal you're
fighting for a title what is this WWWE
[Music]
yeah y it's a great look at all the
stories in this fight card though I know
it's the best card ever my girl was a k
our friend Tiger's dad just bought a new
house he's having a party on Saturday I
was
like you think I'm going to go there UFC
296 you told I said [__] off
yeah come on baby dude don't be
disrespectful come on now I can't go
there you know it's a big UFC night I'm
gonna call you I'm gonna be like what's
up bud you won't answer never hey man
you watching fight I don't look get my
phone during the
fights even the undercards lit you had
Dustin jacobe on the [__] pre prelims
against Alonzo men field great C you got
Cody garbrandt Brian kellerer our boy
what is Kobe can I see uh Cody Cody's uh
garbrandt yeah can I see his record he's
had a tough one I know what you're doing
here no I'm just asking question I'm
allow to ask question don't shame Cody
he won his last one there you
go before that was tough yeah he's had
five losses but a lot of wins before two
out his last seven it's tough it's tough
he's the man though yeah um and it's
that bantamweight what's that it's at
bantamweight yeah
yeah
um it's where he belongs flyweight was a
disaster
yeah what are your thoughts on that
fight I'm I mean I'm taking Cody all day
I love Brian but yeah tough fight for
Cody yeah very tough fight very very
tough fight especially if people are
questioning your chin Brian hits like a
[__] tank awful fight UFC is not
doing me any favors no UFC doesn't do
favors unless you're certain
Fighters man really unless you're Conor
there's no
favors done a good job who's had a good
job Dana White in UFC and way he has a
good job they've done a good job because
I'm excited as [__] oh this fight card
uhhuh yeah it's phenomenal I mean you
know it's UFC 296 Real Housewives of the
UFC that's what they should call this
real housewives of the UFC the only
competes with it is span Washington with
Brian gallon UFC 296 should just called
Drama there's so much drama here drama
uh go uh let's see what else you
got oh oh you want current events I
guess so right and we can start current
events let's get into C EV go ahead by
the way I feel like this press
conference that's going to happen will
probably be one of the bigger ones
because of all this drama which would be
great for the UFC obviously Pantoja and
Brandon Roy Val are going be like what
the [__] I know dude we didn't get two
where it we're the co-main event you
have SE like shut your [__]
mouth yeah it's going to get nasty with
Ian and Colby I just can't wait get
nasty that's why Leon's just like so
classy he's like whatever just rolls
with it but Ian and Colby on there oh
yeah and then shot's bad English dude
take my
money yeah and Ian said he's going to
show up too I think I heard I read
somewhere he's going to show up cuz
people thought cuz he wasn't in the
embedded episodes that maybe he would
not want want to show up but yeah he
should show up he should yeah all right
what's this so uh Jake Paul's fight is
actually this Friday I didn't realize it
was coming so quickly dude someone so
Jake Paul put I'm the biggest name in uh
Combat Sports and then right under it
someone goes dude you're fighting
Saturday nobody knows yeah like I just
saw the weigh-ins this morning and I was
like oh my goodness this is I and I
don't know why Paul is doing this it's
like who are you doing this for unless
it's for himself
he can prove he can compete with legit
boxers but you're not you're making less
money it's a tougher fight you're doing
the same amount of training you're
making less money less people are going
to see it who is this Andre augus guy a
like a low-level pro boxer just like a
guy literally and Paul's still a minus
650 favorite that's strange it sounds
like he's
uh like doing this for himself to see
how but he but also maybe he's doing to
the haters too be like look I beat a
real boxer see you wanted me to fight a
boxer be like no we don't care like
that's never going to go away mhm yeah
never he has to beat like a Canelo
before those haters and like there you
go you know it's not happening yeah so
keep fighting the old MMA guys and
making all the money we all tune in this
I didn't know what's going on I didn't
think about it I hope he wins I like
Jake I hope he wins sounds like you well
might my 650 is a huge favorite but yeah
nobody's talking about what's it on even
uh does
okay I'll definitely watch
it all right so I have been scouting the
next top athletes for the NFL tip move
I'm very good at my job chin check out
this
monster one AR minute Big Daddy Let's Go
dreads man oh man that kid's got to get
on a
diet well yeah not good it goes down
pretty easily that's fine understandable
he's a big boy but one-handed that's
impressive one-handed it's probably the
highlight of his athletic career
I all down what yeah this guy in
Australia got into a fight with the
shark and yet had the time to film his
leg being bit off what he filmed it oh
yeah dude whatever it takes for the
Graham we'll show a little bit of this
but obviously not show us all of it m me
on the episode
oh but they already got him I want to
see the shark
well he have a selfie
stick what language is this Italian is
this Italian Australian accent please
that's all we get that's all you get
yeah I wanted more that's kind of hurt
like a what kind of shark was it it says
monster shark I need more yeah out there
it has to be great I think or or um or
or a tiger shark or a bull shark bull I
would imagine bull I don't Australia
though lot of great white Central out
there but it looks so sh like shallow
he's right next to I think he swam in
right
guys much his leg did he he probably
swam in right guys oh gosh Man without
without a
leg uh let's see you got a tie tourni
around that hold on think about if
you're the guy that there is look at how
much blood that's crazy that sucks so
bad great white shark Maul cap kayaker
after
capiz but look what he says here lost
his leg my grandfather protected me no
it says I no longer have a leg but I'm
alive that's and they no the key to that
whole statement is my grandfather
protected not good enough well where was
he when the shark was ripping your leg
off looking kid with a with a with Aid
with a little [__] African gry on his
shoulder African Greyhound smartest
that's the smartest in the world right
it's called an African love that Brian
knows that's an African gray they can
speak more words they can literally they
can say come and tickle me they they
literally have sense yeah they can take
a bunch of words who gives a [__] though
no but they know what they're saying
kind of crazy this kid got his leg bit
off by a shark and you're highlighting
the that bird saved him dude that's his
grandpa that bird dive bombed his dead
Grandpa reincarnated in shark in the eye
I like this poor kid's leg gets ripped
off K's like sweet bird you know that
bird the kids like what the by the way
it bit him right on the knee like that's
fun they're going to try to save his
knee so it probably bit him right below
the knee or like on the knee that would
suck there's a GoFundMe though no
insurance no insurance well 78,000 is
already pretty dang good that cover no
it's not GNA but I'm saying that's
pretty good that would suck so bad a
shark just puts your whole [__] leg
in his mouth that much that's a lot of
meat right there see that [__] dude I'll
take that that looks delicious
Oh I thought I thought sharks don't
attack humans the [__] out of here um so
here's another one Kanye is back to
being Kanye I don't think there's much
to say about this um you guys can go
here well it's a black hood though I
it's still a a
hood yeah but we're always looking for
[__] it doesn't it's all weird is just
doing like this weird shock but also
just make good music dude he dropped
that sample the back street boys yeah
and then the back street boys are like
we didn't give you authority to do that
really we did not consent but he
released it and back Street's like hey
man you ow money it's funny I think he's
going to weather any storm right he's
kind of untouchable now right he's so
talented his music so good um it's just
different the Jew thing was tough mhm
yeah yeah but he weathered that storm
the black KK hood is tough yeah it's
it's tough to be a fan of his you know
but he just knows how to ride that edge
cuz we're all like yeah but it's a black
hood and also he's with black people and
also he's black and it's like oh you
know he just knows and he's so famous no
one in the back was like you really you
want to wear that yeah like no one was
like he do you have to I'm not telling
him anything um well that's the problem
that's why he's in this situation it's
like even Machado Gary no one's telling
him anything that's the problem this is
the craziest [__] ever so if any of your
wives have her's bags you know who this
guy is so this guy's the heir to the 11
billion AMZ for Fortune has no one to
give the money to and is adopting his
52-year-old Gardener and just passing it
on to him Gardner's all yes dude that is
actually incredible yeah he's unmarried
has no children of his own stands to
pass down billions of dollars to the
arm's Fortune currently valued 220
billion he's only get 11 billion air so
he's only one of the sons he's only one
of the kids but only 11 Bill he owns he
owns Five to six% of the
house yeah uh I'd like to see this
Gardener who's gonna go on a binge and
ruin all hisone I don't know if you can
spend a 11 bill you can't I would like
some of that money I don't I don't think
you can you can that's one like you when
they win the lottery they get 100
million they're not going to show his
face I could buy 100 million in trucks I
can do that I can buy properties 11 bill
would be you got be he probably he
probably thinks that that uh he white G
no no no that's a [__] no he probably
thinks that gardener most decent man
he's ever met when you're wait a minute
if you're a gardener when you're a
gardener I got I got a story for you
when you're a gardener for that dude
okay you know everything about you're
you're an artist you're a [__] Hau
you're like a a zen master so I got
something for you on the I talked to the
Brian gave his Gardener 20 bucks I
talked to the foremost expert on trees
you want to hear something crazy about
trees the foremost expert on trees no no
no
oh no no no this is going to blow oh my
god dude going blow your [__] mind
did you do this for the C out watch this
watch this holy Fu watch this though
watch this give it to me when a deer
starts eating so so how how do trees
communicate they communicate yeah they
communicate like literally the way we
communicate how do they do it I don't
know anybody through the roots smoke no
so not Roots there is there is basically
fungi under it's like mushroom fungi
it's like a web it's literally like uh
the Internet it's literally like this
but listen listen listen listen this is
this is fascinating this is fascinating
I'm listening so it's like this this uh
whatever [__] is right okay when a deer
starts eating the tree over here right
here this tree sends a message to this
tree and this tree and the message is
hey dude I'm getting eaten by a [__]
deer
raise the tannin levels in your leaves
make your leaves super bitter um or
you're going to get eaten so this tree
turns their leaves within a half hour
too bitter for the deer to eat it and
they talk to each other and what's up
now vegans and and you want to give us
[__] for killing pigs and eating cows
you're the trees communicate like the
pigs do how about this then you get two
like giant redwoods but you have a
little tree but why does that that
little tree is getting zero sunlight so
how is it growing H interesting how's it
growing communism the large
trees give these trees
nutrients okay like it's their kids like
it's their kids I got one even [__]
better for hey real quick one question
was this podcast more than four minutes
it wasn't a podcast it was I was having
dinner in in England Oh I thought this
guy is the bnst to the Queen of England
and she's dead now so he's the one who's
in charge of King of England now the
king
so um I thought you're saying this is a
podcast yeah and then there was some
other insane thing where when the now
when the [__] fungi that is giving
messages to the trees if the trees don't
give some of their nutrients to the
fungi the [__] fungi cuts that tree
off turn on him this is all
scientifically documented there is a
whole world going on and they're all
talking each other where you go f what
the [__] is going on here it's Fernly
it's Fern Gully it's Fern Gully and oh a
a tree itself when an insect starts
eating the tree on this side the tree
will tell the leaves over here hey guys
turn your tannin up tannin tastes bitter
yeah it's [__] nuts that's just one
takes them a half an hour to change
literally less sometimes yeah it should
be less right it can change their whole
body but but the crazy thing is the tree
next to them all the trees next to them
get the get a message and fruit does the
same right and those trees that got the
message will give that tree nutrients
like hey thanks a lot here's a little
something for you get the [__] out of
here it's a different world man a't that
crazy wild wild it's basically exactly
how human beings it's like you if you
want to treat others do here's my
marking brain take notes IM Gary's wife
here's my marking brain that guy start a
podcast called trees gone wild he should
because there'd be a lot of people that
would actually be into it but yeah I
don't think so but again you have to
know about trees I mean you have to know
well that's why we're listening to it so
his dumb ass educates us on trees yeah
yeah yeah trees gone wild God and he's
he travels all over the world just to
see trees there's a tree that lived that
that's 8,000 years old 8,000 years old
it's in the uh it's in like I think
Joshua Tree actually it's out there like
right in the state I'd rather be in
solitary or it's in some really really
dry area 8,000 years old 8,000 is the
oldest tree ah vandals cut it
down yeah van were like let's think he
tells his family he's like babe they
just called me I got to get out to this
Redwood by thday she's like it's not
going anywhere he brings his family with
him everywhere yeah and they're all like
this he goes this is the first year
where his wife was like hey can we go to
Hawaii and not go to [__] there's
trees in Hawaii at trees go at palm
trees can we you know palm trees talk
normal vacation instead of you taking us
somewhere in the middle of the Congo to
look at a tree all trees matter his
family's made of wood yeah what do you
got Chen [__] I forgot about that about
trees all right so did you guys see this
stuff this footage about claressa Shield
sparring another boxer named AR arter I
don't know how toos and he posted video
took the padding out of his yeah yeah so
she's accusing so she say she's never
been dropped or knocked out in like 17 I
don't know how many years or something
but I'll show you real quick so there's
the
footage everybody gets
caught
oh that's a assault
Brother God d dog that's how good she is
homeboy going all
out uh so she's accusing him of taking
the padding out of the gloves and then
this is her actually talking about it
here yep this gets crazy yeah are we
positive you took the padding out no no
so this is her accusation about it she's
a pretty girl that's why Karma EA your
ass that's why you dealing with what you
dealing with now with your health issues
because you is a individual he know he
talking about some these gloves were
gifted by Roberto the ran to me and I
didn't know that the padding was that
much in there the padding had the gloves
in the padding had zero to no pading
that's what it's about you think I got a
problem with getting dropped it's boxing
it happens I don't been here heart I
done seen Stars I don't got hear like
where where I where I couldn't eat for
three days sping against heavyweight
coming up when I was 17 I don't give a f
about being dropped but what I will say
is when a try to cheat me you got me
[__] up and yes I ran to my car and I
grabbed my knife and I was going to cut
Derek Santos guess who stopped post John
godamn because I will slice his old ass
up cuz don't ever cheat against me I'm
not mad about getting dropped and
anybody who think that I am mad about it
uh you a you a fool oh so the guy the
guy admitted he's like oh I didn't know
there was in padding cuz he they
probably confirmed it robberto dur gave
me these gloves in 1960 get her goddamn
knife like [__] from Detroit Detroit
girl she's hard I'll let her beat me up
mhm she's hard she's a tough
cookie uh have you guys seen this video
yet or no yeah it's no I haven't seen it
okay so I'll play for you it's actually
amazing me and Georgie seen this video
but I guess sonaz hasn't and brenon you
haven't so just check this out this is
really really powerful it's really good
it's another Eddie Murphy video it's
about men's or just mental health oh wow
how you doing you
guys oh sorry thank you how you doing
God it's exciting isn't it
so uh as as the
weekly
[Music]
yeah things are better
outside oh
wow
are they actors yeah watch
[Applause]
[Music]
this
no
yep it's pretty bad ass yeah he died he
killed his friend my gosh Bron no his
friend his he murdered his friend he did
that cuz it made us like not be so sad
look how serious bride is no it's FR
committed suicide no [__] you can't you
can't
see mental illness yeah clearly bro he
got rid of his body
though try back on the you [__] it up
getting all serious guys he killed his
friend I'm looking at her she doesn't
get she I was like 50 million views in
like 6 days great video dude that's it's
such a good video yeah that is sad I
know but it's like it's it's good to
know this kind ofu I bet on the wrong
dog I guy on the left com in suicide he
cries My Cries my arms after every
[__] podcast Brian was like that was
so
powerful I said it was so powerful it is
uh this another one's from sinas I just
saw this and thought it was amazing and
I don't I don't know if it's real is a
halftime show it could
be Let me refresh birthday it's my
birthday come on that's real that's
pretty crazy that's real yeah
it's pretty
cool that's nuts so how high he gets how
is he getting that high jumps jumps off
yeah just does a big back
flip I thought I got take it easy
someone said the those boards were made
of Cinnamon Toast
Crunch they must be like the lightest
they're super light yeah see super light
I'd rather see him Dunka basketball that
yeah that' been that' been more
surprising to be
honest I think that's it that's it all
right UFC 296 going down this freaking
Saturday watch the fight companion live
with Cheeto Vera Rampage Jackson myself
that starts at 700 p.m. Pacific Time on
thick boy YouTube uh tour dates I'll be
torn around La but I'm in Nashville
January 25th then two shows in Austin
that's January 26 27th get your tickets
at thick boy.com guys off the hook
comedy club I'm in Span this Friday
Saturday then off the hook Comedy Club
you know where that is in Naples Florida
uh December 21 22 23 and then Comedy
Zone Charlotte December 28 29 3031 let's
go no I'm sorry December 29
3031 uh that's Charlotte Comedy Zone
I'll see you there love you guys all
right guys love you